cette vidéo est faite en partenariat
avec google j'ai un gros problème avec
la cuisine j'ai un gros problème genre
je me fais pas manger quoi je vais pas à
manger
swatch commandes soit j'ai des plats
surgelés que je réchauffe
soit je m'arrange pour manger en
extérieur avoir des rendez-vous et
cetera soit je vais chez ma mère ou ma
grand mère et je repars à ghetto perwer
quoi mais je me fais pas à manger c'est
un vrai problème c'est un vrai problème
parce que déjà j'ai l'impression de
manger gens mangent de la merde quoi
enfin j'ai tout le temps trop gras tout
temps trop salés sucrés machin faire je
sais pas mais il ya un truc de trop quoi
tout le temps sauf évidemment les plats
faits par ma mère et ma grand-mère que
j'embrasse je dis ma grand mère c'est
mes grands mères j'ai émises je les ai
unifiée pour que ce soit plus simple
aussi le fait que clermont ça me coûte
un bras et au delà de ça
je me sens nul en fait j'ai honte je me
dis ok le mec ne se fait même pas à
manger ce qui est quand même la base
c'est que quand google ils m'ont
contacté il ya quelques semaines dans le
cadre de leur campagne chercher nous
fait avancer et qui m'ont dit bah vas-y
ça peut être cool de voila quoi que tu
changes un truc dans ta routine que tu
casses une habitude et c'est pour
avancer en fait c'était évident que ce
que je voulais changer c'était ça donc
je me suis dit que c'était une
opportunité pour essayer de changer
cette habitude
de m'améliorer là dedans et de si
possible être fier de moi si possible
alors pour vous dire à quel point ça me
travaille ce truc de cuisine je vous
l'avait balancé dans mes résolutions
dans ma newsletter
janvier 2021 alors les gens qui
découvrent que j'ai newsletters on en
parlera plus tard et j'avais hui la
chose suivante pour la cuisine je pense
que ça peut être une bonne chose que je
me force à faire à manger régulièrement
en utilisant la règle des deux jours en
gros interdiction de ne pas se faire à
manger plus de deux jours de suite
sachant qu'aujourd'hui c'est une ou deux
fois par semaines max et non on ne va
pas commenter mon budget bouffe qui est
exposée depuis que je vis seul pour
m'aider je me rajouter des contraintes
un live instagram uche cuisine
hebdomadaire c'est un truc fun à faire
et ça donnera une raison de cuisiner
quand on sortira du coc vide
j'inviterais des gens pour rendre tout
ça plus plaisant
évidemment j'ai jamais invité personne
et j'ai arrêté le live instagram car en
voyant ces règles là je mens compte
qu'elles sont pas mal changé en fait
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est plutôt si il
y à deux repas de suite chez moi où je
suis seule et qui sont pas cuisiner le
troisième doit être cuisinés mais il
suffit que je sorte un mois en bois un
repas
et sahara mais le truc à 0 oui je dis
que j'invite quelqu'un les armes les
trucs à 0 autant vous dire qu'avec mes
rendez-vous les tournages et que c'était
en fait c'est assez rare que je sois
vraiment obligé dans ma règle de cuisine
et un truc mais avant de me mettre à
cuisiner faut que je comprenne pourquoi
j'aime pas cuisiner
bds que j'aime pas cuisiner en fait ce
que j'ai dit pourquoi j'aime pas
cuisiner mais la vraie question c'est
pourquoi je ne cuisine pas est ce que
j'aime pas cuisiner banon que j'aime
bien franchement c'est cool tu vois
c'est cool je mets cuisinés
ok alors pourquoi je ne cuisine pas
eh bien je pense que c'est parce que je
trouve que ça me prend trop de temps ça
que tout le temps que je vais mettre à
cuisiner et tout ce qui va avec c'est à
dire mettre les trucs les enlever les
laver tout ça à machin
c'est du temps que où je bosse pas en
fait vu que je pose beaucoup voilà ça me
frustre moi j'aime bien quand ça prend
genre cinq minutes quoi c'est pour ça
qu'un de mes plats préférés basse et les
pâtes instantanées quoique un peu plat
préféré que je fais c'est les pâtes
instantanées parce que je prends mon
sachet pâte paf ça mais une minute
trente ou trois minutes suivant les
types de pâtes et où je mets un filet
d'huile d'olive et zhao basta cosi mais
bon des pâtes instantanées que de
l'huile d'olive c'est pas fifou quoi
donc c'est peut-être aussi ça peut-être
que c'est pas assez stimulant pour me
donner envie de le faire donc je vous
dis je devrais peut-être me rapprocher
d'experts quoi des gens qui qui s'y
connaissent vraiment qu'ils savent ce
qu'ils font des chefs en fait et des
chefs ça tombe bien j'en connais
jean marc gorny le mec a fait top chef
rose il tient un superbe restaurant
appareil qui s'appelle goguette et
surtout le mec est une crème il en fait
mais il en est une ouais et de marco ça
va
je tenterais bien j'avais réfléchi à
genre d mignot recettes de trucs à faire
qu'ils prennent cinq minutes et que
toucher les améliore tu vois comme ça je
te dis comme ça je te demandais pas
travailler trop tu vois ce que je
voulais pas prendre trop de temps faut
pas que ça dépasse 5 degrees max tu vois
pas ce que moi ce que j'avais pensé à la
base c'était par exemple tu vas genre
les pâtes riz pâtes fraîches
tu vois ça prend deux minutes tu
rajoutes de l'huile d'olive c'est bon
quoi ce que veut dire moi c'était moi je
moi mon niveau il était très bas mon
niveau il était chez ba et il faut et en
gros il faut en terme de nombre soit moi
mon but c'est de faire une semaine quoi
là je me dis qu'à une dizaine de
recettes à faire facilement je pas tout
les montrer dans cette vidéo on va se
concentrer sur cinq recettes par exemple
et pour les noter je prends mon outil de
notes favori google keep sanusi jeu 10
puis genre cinq ans six ans je pense
gelé sur tous mes appareils
soit des appareils android ou ios
d'ailleurs c'est des listes ou des notes
que j'utilise pour tout et n'importe
quoi ça peut être des idées de vidéos
savez chez soi on a tous une sorte de
tiroir de la mort qu'on ouvre et j'en
sais il ya tout dans 20 mois c'est
google qui ça me permet de mettre plein
de choses dans mes notes des médias et
tous des check list et pour les
retrouver c'est l'outil de recherche de
google donc c'est hyper puissant et pour
le reste je me dis que jen marco va me
donner quelques tips donc j'invite j'en
ai pas de frêche franchement ça se fait
en une minute 32 minutes moi ça fait
partie du peu de plats que je fais parce
que ça prend très peu de temps tu vois
et je me suis dit ça serait bien si on
pouvait les pimpé facilement donc tu
m'as dit sauce monte pecorino moi je
rappelle justement c'est tout simplement
une sauce pour changer un peu les
épopées un peu c'est un terrible pour
donner un goût un peu plus frais pour
changer un peu le goût de tenter
prochain plairont de la cale de la crête
kwc
ciseaux et tueurs du pecorino dedans une
fois que les intéristes ont pris je ne
te dans le queens à 30 secondes dans la
crème étude dresse ensuite vous faire un
gratin du reste des tartines mirana avec
sauce mornay ce sera évidemment de
minutes ce que j'adore ci-contre la
pièce phare utiliser des vieilles
recettes de la dgi française a souvent
mené c'est une vieille précède la chimie
française qu'on ne dise plus c'est une
béchamel à m'énerver avec a9 et du
parmesan avec cette sauce mormeck est
tout simplement de la farine du beurre
mélangée à du lait notre esprit
casserole ouais en fait fondre une
pierre de beurre ouais on rajoute une
couche saline on mélange très on ajoute
on veut dire en verre de lait ok on
mélange une fois potabilisation on
ajoute du fromage et neuf se fait une
sauce qu'on va souhaite entraîner comme
et autres tartes salées batteur notre
ken canada regret c'est super facile tu
prends de la pâte déjà l'acheter ouais
c'est la pâte brisée ou de la pâte à
pizza de même ça veut dire que tu le
mets dans un plat chaud un plat mettre
au four ouais tu prends du bon tabac ont
su prendre le bio peut garder la peau le
seul groupe à outils des passes quand on
connaît le coût des turbines cela il
faut 30 minutes baird s'est jamais rien
oui un truc que je fais facilement juste
la salade tu vois genre la salade
jachère que ça chez tout est déjà là tu
vois je pense h est je le vis dans le
saladier je rajoute peut-être une
mozzarella que de couper en deux
secondes des betteraves parfois tu vois
je rajoute un peu de graines de courge
ou sauce un peu de sauce soja vinaigre
balsamique huile d'olive est pas ça me
fait ça là toi qu'est-ce que je peux
rajouter dans ce plat à pour que ce soit
j'ai deux possèdent donné que je te
laisse beaucoup les avons maintes fois
tu m'as de la menthe trop de du basilic
frais du place et de la croyance ce que
tu peux faire ça un jour tu te prends ah
tu peux faire un petit pesto par exemple
transmis aux trois minutes tâche toutes
les armes au sens où tu prends une botte
de morne des modes de corps découverts
au niveau de sa faillite il battait
persique tâche tous ensemble tu es d un
petit pot qui t'a avec un peu d'huile
comme ça les avait gardé un goût et
chaque fois tu fais ta salade suis tue
mais que cette vinaigrette 7 7 6 qui
doit vraiment un côté de fraîcheur et à
un moment ça va booster ta salade est ce
que tu vas faire aussi des petits pics
d'oignons c'est très simple c'est très
très simple tu prends attendu entre le
coupé en petits morceaux ouais et dans
une boîte qui fait bouillir tente autant
au sucre vinaigre blanc et tu verses
août à sauter
sauter sauter l'oignon et ça fait des
piquets de nous une petite recette
supplémentaire celle du tout aux
japonais je prends deux autres ouais tu
le couvent en petits morceaux
a assuré moi tu mélange avec de la
mayonnaise mais si on a trouvé deux
tranches de pain de mie et tuent presque
du groupe en triangle et c'est à 9,12 à
un goûter qui mangent les enfants
japonais comme ça
c'est tout ça vous êtes des oeufs la
mairesse et le pain et penderie blanc
est sur le bord très gourmand
la bayonnaise et la maillot je peux la
faire dos et l'autre à des bonne
mayonnaise aujourd'hui bon là un souci
c'est que mon coach n'aime pas trop la
maillot puisque je suis youtuber donc
j'ai forcément un coach c'est une loi
qui est passé depuis septembre 2021 je
sais pas si vous avez vu tous les
youtube en des coachs il faut suivre du
coup il faut que les remplaçants et
moins gras
hop du houmous maintenant est-ce que je
peux vraiment faire tout ça en moins de
cinq minutes c'est ce qu'on va voir tout
de suite
moi la partie d un peu plus de cinq
minutes mais je me dis que si je prépare
mes cube al avance et que je couds
plusieurs batteurs net pour faire
plusieurs start ça peut passer en fait
je retiens trois éléments de ce que me
dit john marco d'abord il en faut peu
pour rendre un plat beaucoup plus stylé
qui peut parler d'un season est à salade
avec
déjà des sauces préparées ou tu mets un
peu de moutarde avec des huiles de ce
qui est cool ça peut être viser des
différents vinaigre
balsamique tu as des vinaigres et
puissant c'est cool quand un le vinaigre
de cidre tu as deviné qui touche les
habitudes est ce que tu fais tu es
blanches et roses et une bouteille que
tu gardes quiétude au frigo au lieu de
fata vinaigrette chaque fois bachata
vinaigrette effet comme ça déjà le temps
que tu ranges les bouteilles at-on
plaque a battu gates en seconde et 30
secondes sur cinq minutes c'est beaucoup
c'est beaucoup ensuite vous faire plus
et utiliser les restes par exemple pour
un gratin ou pour une soupe et ensuite
vous faire des préparations qu'on peut
mettre au congélo est activée rapidement
je crois que si j'ai bien compris ça
s'appelle du match pour king ça veut on
va se mettre une heure deux heures sur
préparer plein de choses cuisiner plein
de choses et après même les cuirs et
toulon et mets dans un tupperware
extrait on les mange le plus tard c'est
une technique aussi pour que ça prenne
beaucoup moins de temps de cuisiner nous
aussi on fait on ne fait pas la
préparation de tous les jeux ea de
préparation comme un autre jour pour
faire des gosses purée ou qu'on doit
faire des sauces bas on les fait pour
trois jours on a pas on peut pas faire
toujours pas ce que c'est au fait que le
tage tous les jours les journées sont
assez longues donc on a des tâches que
tous vos trois jours et même même pour
moi des fois je veux faire des petites
barquettes que je garde au congélateur
pour cause de la flemme et parce que
c'est ce
que tu fais une fois et tu congélation
est en fête s'est passé un truc
intéressant c'est que en cuisinant tout
ça ça va un peu reconnecter à la cuisine
et ça m'a fait réaliser que j'ai un
petit regret quand même c'est de ne pas
savoir cuisiner de plats iranien
j'en parle jamais sur la chaîne youtube
mais je suis né en france mes deux
parents sont iraniens et donc je suis ce
qu'on appelle un immigré de deuxième
génération et comme beaucoup d'émigrés
deuxième génération en fait j'ai très
peu de lien avec mon pays d'origine ça
mérite une vidéo dédiée je pense mais
dans la cuisine la joie une petite
brèche et je me dis que je vais
apprendre mon plat végétarien iranien
préférées auch est resté je pourrais
demander à ma grand mère comme on en
fait un mais j'ai plutôt envie de lui
faire une petite surprise donc à base de
quelques recherches google je trouve une
bonne recette mais par contre je réalise
que pour certains ingrédients c'est
compliqué je les ai pas forcément est en
fait ils sont trouvables nulle part quoi
il faut une épicerie granier et je sais
absolument pas où est ce qu'il ya une
épicerie rania évidemment il ya mon
allié de toujours google maps et au
passage j'utilise aussi google maps pour
tous mes restaurants favoris et les
restaurants j'en ai testé j'ai juste un
truc chez moi c'était un sac d'herbe
mais j'aime pas trop ce que c'était est
ce qu'il y avait forcément dedans et à
quoi ça servait du coup j'ai fait une
recherche par image quoi avec google
labs les à google dance vous permet
aussi d'avoir des traductions sur
l'image ski défense j'en ai pas eu
besoin parce que je parle couramment
iranien évidemment c'est faux mais je me
débrouille quand même pas mal sauf lire
et écrire sa chemise euro et donc je
suit l'itinéraire et je débarque dans le
quartier iranien paris parce que oui il
ya un quartier iranien ça c'est un resto
iranien ça c'en est un autre et voilà
voilà la petite épicerie raed
salah ses gâteaux j'adore ce book trop
bon ça c'est du reste et que j'avais pas
du tout des nouilles de blé tendre ont
fait le plein de légumineuses
et ensuite c'est parti pour sur la
recette
et après c'est parti pour ce que l'art
cette anecdote je savais pas qu'il
fallait tremper les haricots rouges
autant de temps et c'est donc j'ai dû
décaler la surprise à ma grand mère de
24 heures
et donc j'ai pu faire beaucoup
[Musique]
oui car oui merci rochelle à colmater
les brèches à la surprise et thiais se
fait l'essai
raza ironie toskala et travaux alors
sitôt l'oscar des
travaux archi j'ai chuté
si
[Musique]
pauline bonaparte la petite mercy et
s'est fait jeter si je sais
ce pont
bravo à
ben
bravo à tous les niveaux dans ce réseau
les jolis traits de certains frais
licorne libérer 12 dorées de laure connu
tout cela je passais du sto la baratte
eric elmosnino matou stora à guimaëc
monomoteur chevaucha roubaud a choisi
mais koné
kafana pas la fête aux portes et café
libertaire michel aulas dans le chemin
waouh begin in ruda michel da ou dark
blood in childhood à
maria tomé à celle là n'a pas
semé chez karthala
s'agit
surprenait à césar
turmel s'exporter avorter
elle est vraiment trop mignonne hammami
8 sur 10 vraiment ça méritait un
3 je pense donc deux points pour les
forts je suis hyper content d'avoir fait
cette vidéo
parce que je suis contente ça m'a forcé
en fait la cuisine et des trucs les
différentes recettes que j'ai pu faire
et que j'ai pu améliorer et où elles
sont je vais pas vous mentir c'est pas
officines pour l'instant mais j'aime
bien parce que je vois une piste
d'amélioration et je vois que c'est pas
si compliqué que ça en fait de
s'améliorer et vu que c'est très court
excédé min 07 bah c'est motivant en fait
moins émotive en tout cas je suis
content que voilà qu au moins une fois
dans sa vie ma grand mère en a goûté
à auch hérité de son petit-fils quoi
même s'il était dégueulasse et en fait
je me dis qu'il ya moyen de hacker même
le hsv jeter quoi ça que si je prends
que des trucs de conserves par exemple
pour les légumineuses ce qui prend du
temps et c'est à cuire mais en fait le
recherchiste et il peut se faire assez
vite au final c'est d'ailleurs ce que ma
grand mère m'a avoué qu'elle faisait
quand un homme masqué sa grossesse
peut-être que cette envie de tout hacker
ne vient pas nulle part j'espère que ces
vies vous a plu et je vois c'est encore
google pour l'opportunité de changer ce
truc là parce que j'avoue je me serais
jamais motivé tout seul et je crois que
dans le cadre de leur campagne chercher
nous fait avancer sa saint-céré bien en
fait le fait de d'aller chercher plus
d'informations sur internet pour ensuite
prendre ces infos et essayer de faire
voilà une recette dans le monde sont
possibles et donc changer mes habitudes
et avancer un petit peu dans mon
développement avec sa voix là ça marche
bien je vous remercie vous j'espère que
ça vous a plu j'espère que vous a
inspiré je vous a donné des idées je
remercie évidemment jean marc gorny
n'hésitez pas à aller dans son
restaurant du feu de dieu ait laissé une
petite review sur google maps ça lui
fera plaisir et jouer ainsi ma
grand-mère sans qui je ne serais pas là
évidemment love peace ciao apple est
beau